so at the end of the first section we
posed uh a number of different questions
about antibiotics
the main one being how is it that we
sequence antibiotics um
we're going to get to that but let's
take a detour to learn about another
question which is how is it that
bacteria make antibiotics if we can
learn about this maybe we have some
insights
in terms of how to sequence them
so we described a
an antibiotic peptide as a mini protein
and the question then is how is it that
the cell produces proteins so it starts
at the level of dna this is one of the
many reasons why dna is so important
dna is a double stranded
molecule and it gets transcribed into
rna which is a single stranded molecule
so this is a complex molecular procedure
that for the most part we're not going
to get into but in terms of strings how
we think about this is that
rna has the same bases or similar bases
as dna and so this the g for guanine the
a for adenine and the c for cytosine are
not going to change however the t
which represents thymine and dna gets
represented instead by the base u or
uracil and rna
after this method which is called
transcription dna goes into rna rna is
then translated into peptides or
proteins so
here we have four nucleotide bases
adenine sizes in guanine and uracil and
i mentioned that there are 20 common
amino acids so here are the amino the
table amino acids along with their three
letter codes
and
unlike the the transcription of dna into
rna where we had four letters in each
case
there's not a natural one to one
correspondence here
so
our question is can we translate two
nucleotides at a time could we take all
tumors
a a c a g a u and can we map those into
proteins
the answer is going to be no right we
don't have enough there are going to be
16 of these tumor nucleotide
so we're going to need at least three
nucleotides at a time
and that's going to give us enough
okay and so this motivates the
definition of a codon which is just a
triplet of nucleotides and the genetic
code is the term that we use for the
assignment of codons into single amino
acids in order to make proteins
so here's an example of one codon that
gets sent to
one base so tryptophan is always encoded
by ugg
usually what happens is that you see six
different codons or not necessarily six
different but multiple different codons
so here we have six different codons
going into lysine
or l
you also have three special codons
called stop codons
these serve as messages to halt
translation so they say stop translation
here and
don't continue translating
so these method methods of transcription
and translation represented by beautiful
molecular processes that we encourage
you to learn more about
but that we're interested in on a
computational level
form what are called the central dogma
of molecular biology so we start with
dna it gets transcribed into rna that
gets translated into protein
and this was a term the central dogma of
molecular biology this term was uh
coined in 1958 by francis crick of
watson and quick fame and i always
thought dogma is kind of a strange word
to use
because dogma in english means a belief
that cannot be questioned or overturned
in any circumstance and it's usually
used in a religious context and that's
usually not a word that you see in
science
and crick admitted years later that he
had made a mistake he thought
he realized that he should have used a
synonym that was more appropriate like
principle
but he used the wrong word and now it's
something that we're stuck with and we
should have a hint that because uh we
we've used this word the strange word
dogma there may be some irony there
right maybe that this dogma doesn't
necessarily hold all the time
so assuming that it does hold our goal
is we know a lot about genomes and if we
have sequenced genomes can we look for
the mini protein of
tyrocidine b1
in the genome so can we find a thirdemer
in this bacillus brevis genome that
transcribes into rna and then translates
into the peptide of length 10 that's
represented by tyrosine b1
unfortunately there are going to be
thousands of different 30 merch that
could do this so i'll show three here
right notice that each of these three
dna strings gets translated into the
same string of amino acids
and if we look at the three different
dna strings we can notice that they're
not very similar so there are thousands
of different ones
and they're not very similar so we can't
really draw conclusions by trying to
reverse the process of translation
another thing to learn to notice is that
translation is going to be able to start
pretty much anywhere so by anywhere i
mean it doesn't have to if you look at
this
dna string this dna string here gets
transcribed into an rna string similarly
its reverse complement gets transcribed
into an rna string running in the
opposite direction
when you look at translation though
translation can start at gug in which
case
the translated amino acid is valine
it could also start at u though so it
could start and reading off uga in which
case it's transl translated into a stop
codon and thirdly it could be
read as gaa in which case it becomes
translated into glutamine so we wind up
with six of these different reading
frames or ways of reading off the same
strand of the same molecule of dna three
from this strand running this direction
and three from the reverse complementary
strand running in the opposite direction
we also have this additional fact that
the tyrositian b1 um
peptide like many peptides of of its
kind are is actually cyclic so rather
than just the one
linear representation as a string of 10
amino acids that i've given you we get
10 different representations depending
on where we start
on the string so if we start it at
valene we get one representation if we
start lysing we get a completely
different one
so then we come back to our question and
we say
how many third amer's in the genome of
bacillus brevis are actually going to
encode
one of these linear representations
so this is a question that we ask
and we could go off and and program it
in a computer
and have the computer run
our algorithm
and then our computer would say well
actually there aren't any thermos in
this genome that encode
one of these linear representations so
that's weird and our conclusion then is
that somehow something weird is going on
with this dogma right somehow it's not
getting translated from the dna of
bacillus brevis
so to learn a little bit more about this
process i'll tell you that
i mentioned that it's a beautiful
molecular process
transcription and translation
transcription is carried out by a
molecule called rna polymerase and
translation is carried out by an enzyme
called a ribosome
an obvious idea then to say is it the
case that
these that an antibiotic peptide is
maybe outside of this dogma is to say
well let's shut down the ribosome if the
ribosome is in charge of translation
let's shut it down and see if
these many proteins are still getting
produced so in 1963 that's what edward
tatum does
he inhibits the ribosome in bacillus
brevis
and he hypothesized that all translation
would stop but instead the production of
some peptides including the tyrosines
like tyrocidine b1
keeps going all right so this is a major
sign that the dogma doesn't necessarily
hold in all cases
six years later fritz lipman comes along
and says well these tyrositians are
actually non-ribosomal peptides so
they're synthesized not by the ribosome
but by a completely different process
that relies on a giant protein called
nrp synthetase
now this giant protein is made up of a
number of different mod it's made up of
10 different modules actually and each
module is responsible for adding a
single amino acid to this small peptide
of length 10. so it's a huge peptide
made up of a number of different pieces
and each piece is responsible for just
one amino acid
once the amino acids are added then the
peptide is circularized